після війни історії не матч він і був
вище 1 кан старі права у 4 терміни
мета mouth якщо краще два ти ж не там
досвіду не показував ще ангела Меркель
півтора його рекорд dog та на політичній
сцені для заяв вин мартін шульц
на вигляд min-width ревну мер коль у нього
зовсім in 6 ліс рук увальня
ми хочемо ще плащ ікри не піддавалася
праведними люди могли жити в повній, але й
в достатку щоб не матч вона була
учням стабільності в Європі та з
митаємо наші істоти в баку розколоті
малюку слухайте не а й у сусідніх
європейських країнах загвинчується
внесемо підсилити з кілочка голова
європарламенту мартін шульц
кузова або від кращого антипод фрау
Меркель вин представляє соціал-демократ
його вже до 3 миється ощадливих подивився
позиційна себе захисником прав найман
їхні противники у
у шульца на мою вищу святу і на адже
повне шкільне вінку зайвий спортсмен і
алкоголік кращому винсом не знаєте у
інтерв'ю після того, як 24 сідня мартіна
шульца висунула кандидатом у консилер і
вид партія з дпн полетиш на картина поза
машині стало ризик змінився рейтингу
соціал-демократії stream copy йшли в гору
а рейтинги партій Меркель стала падати і
і стану нашу 100 лютого з дпн померлого
вийшла блок хдс і хсс шульц прикидаєшся
з технічного кандидата слідчі
канал піднятий рейтинг партії на
реальному у суперника марк аль-хакім
соціологи закликати чи поспішають
вапняками і блазнував і на подібний
успіх шульц і з причиною насамперед важливо
масштабну валу виміру пекла виборі до
бундестагу сифона ти ворог у багатого
можна змінити про їхню здатність
протріть cfc до виборів до бундестагу
через нас і переломний момент у місті
показу рану від ж заплутування ми zara
чує 10 адже сотки вибрати його тінню
діас дпн
як партію кому ж ви вирішите проблем
україни колір таким полохливим на дохлу
zing on
у не менше не канцлера прибирай бундестаг
цьому з дпс че потрібно паромах ти на
вибору для того, щоб should ставши
канцлером
гірша волоссі швидко популярніша за раз я
пам'ятного та фініш маркою
нібито вибори були прямими за нього були
би готові проголосувати та
до 50 і адже сотки вибір tell завмер
вище 34 робити цього дня
увага видосе про que todo нового
кандидатів канцлер та праведніше газети
написали прутик ведомий берлінський
стиліст парадом шульцу зголений бороду
ніж виглядають йому кращим і ahai нижчим
ведений журнал шарли огляд на мою акри
яку маркою 2 3 за мою голову та
шульца в руках політолога чекайте на фразу
пари моя
мартін шульц навряд чи кардинально
змінити політику ще до кремля вин
поважається після добрим правильний курс
санкцій за diy Москви в Україні